dit c'est le peuple qui demande les
mesures répressives moi j'ai toujours
l'impression quand il se passe un truc
bien c'est les élites qui ont fait le
bon choix et qu'on perde plus mal c'est
le mauvais peuple mauvais peuple café
lire hitler enfin c'est toutes ces
conneries historique pour dire que
finalement voyez un argument de plus sur
le peuple il veut remplir le congélo il
attend en plus si on nous demande de
voter il va être sécuritaire la totale
des arguments c'est sûr que ça donne pas
envie de démocratie et pourtant ce que
vient de dire emmanuel todd c'est vrai
c'est pas le peuple qui a tiré qui a
mutilé j ai je ne sais pas le peuple qui
a dit percuté les ça les fera réfléchir
au moment de la journée de 3 18 décembre
à paris ici même la la demande de
répression ça d'abord été une demande de
la classe dominante parce
qu'effectivement par là je vaux jour
tout à fait ainsi on devrait aussi on
applique l'agenda de bruxelles qui est
l'agenda qui aussi voulue par les
socialistes français qui est aussi voulu
par macron donc voilà auxquels notre
caste dominante française est tout à
fait consentante c'est un régime
d'appauvrissement c'est un régime de
brises et les protections sociales de
briser l'assurance chômage donc c'est
mettre des gens à bout et donc derrière
la réponse qu'on a elle est répressive
lé psychiatre is an tu parce que du coup
maintenant les gens sont en souffrance
donc on va les psychiatrisés leur leur
souffrance sociale
c'est c'est france télécom c'est
derrière tout un tas d'experts qui vont
à essayer d'analyser la souffrance au
travail sans jamais parler
d'exploitation au travail donc on va
vers cette société de contrôle et elle
vient cette société de contrôle vient
uniquement de l'an viii de la classe
dominante d'aller jusqu'au bout de son
agenda de voir la difficulté qu'elle a
parce qu'elle a ses difficultés quand
même parce qu'en france il ya les
mouvements sociaux y'a pas de référendum
mais il ya des mouvements sociaux et ça
reste quand même des cailloux dans leurs
chaussures le dernier en date c'était
quand même la réforme des retraites la
réforme des retraites la classe
dominante française le veut mais le veux
terriblement c'est une évidence pour
elle elle ne supporte pas cette idée
qu'on puisse payer des gens à rien faire
c'est c'est insupportable pour elle elle
veut briser ce système là elle veut le
faire en plus de façon technique elle
veut qu'ils aient plus de débat le
régime par points c'était il ya plus de
débat c'est chaque année y aura des
experts qui croiseront des courbes et
qui diront ah bah tiens faut travailler
plus longtemps parce que la conjoncture
le veut donc ça c'était leur idéal il
s'agira même de bouger le du point on
trouvera c'était vraiment leur kif quoi
c'était se dire il y aura plus besoin
devrait même plus besoin de passer par
l'assemblée nationale ça se fera au
comité d'orientation des retraites etc
donc j'étais à ça à sa de la voix et
puis il ya eu des grosses manifestations
et puis bon il ya ulcos vite donc pour
sauver coville
[Musique]